[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we're going into uncharted
territory I see the hole it's shaped
like a rabbit and we're gonna dive in
after it you leave it right there so
there's an envelope here that has a
question or a statement or something
from a fan from a mythical beasts yes
and we use that as a jumping off point
to go where the conversation leads
follow the White Rabbit know is that
what we're doing no no no we don't want
a white rabbit it's just a rabbit
I thought the rabbits a rabbit hole no
rabbit tread and Alice in Wonderland
it's white right yes I'm not being
racist I'm just saying that's what it
was
I thought that was a drug reference I
just want to make sure we weren't making
any I do think it is a drug we're not
making the drug reference you know we're
not you can make a drug inference we
want that would be you doing that yeah
that's your problem
we don't make references you make
inferences that's what makes the world
go round
um but before we do we should we should
catch up a little bit because it's the
only time we have legitimate
conversations with each other that's not
true not true we talk to each other but
we do save conversations for this forum
I mean it's um what we haven't talked
about is we're at that point in the year
in the fresh year when it starts to dawn
on you that the resolutions that you
made and that the paths that you well
laid are not being well trodden or are
they you know I you know I I just wonder
you did you fall into a new year's
resolution trap I don't matter and are
you are you in it or have you escaped
I don't made resolutions I'm I know I I
don't call what I do resolution you did
the most cliche thing right uh I started
going to the gym I'm already resolved no
get back in there let's clarify things
here I've been going to the gym I've
been going to Pilates class oh that's um
for two days out of the week for about a
year now consists
it's been great for my self-image to say
that I'm a Pilates man it's been great
for my back but the one thing that I
have noticed is that it's great for like
your back but I feel like you know I
turned 40 last year I'm not doing
anything to get the heart rate up to
someplace that does good things for
there's not there's no cardio in Pilates
you can work really hard but know it you
may get an elevated heart rate at times
but it's more about core and balance and
strength and you're not gonna you don't
put any muscle on you just gain strength
and peace peace
I gained some peace from it there's a
that's what the PMPA stands for it's
actually an acronym peace intentionality
love affection tension exceptionalism
and Socrates because the whole thing is
based on Socrates I made all that up on
the spot that's the kind of thing that
happens but listen but on an air biscuit
when you say it would have been great
and it's of you if you wouldn't have
said I made up if you don't Brack you
bragged at the end and it just it just
shriveled away just like your resolution
to get it no no no no so it's not a
resolution I well one of the things that
happened is I see my wife in there by
the way no it was a different time
Christy started going to the same place
because she you know with her head
injury I don't know if I've ever talked
about her head injury it's weird that I
never thought about but she has she's
suffering from post concussion syndrome
from for having you make it sound like
his head wound Harry or something you
remember you remember that SNL character
Harry who was it I think it was Dana
Carvey I wasn't it well I think there I
know it's paid Will Ferrell but I have
no clue who had wound Harry Harry it was
a guy he would just join us in public
who head-wound Harry was played by and
it was just he had a gaping open wound
on his head that like part of his brain
was showing and he got in on things like
he would go to a party he would like get
it on things they probably only did it
once but it happened at a certain point
in my childhood so that it's iconic in
my memory you know you have those things
where you're a certain age we're
certain changes are happening in your
life and the entertainment that you were
enjoying at that point in your life
becomes this iconic thing that you will
never ever forget in head-wound Harry
that era Dan carved Harvey my first
guess was correct
my my doppelganger yeah yeah and so
Christie has a gaping using bloody head
wound she's been walking around
embarrassing for over a year and Pilates
really helped it's a story for another
time except to say she was it was it was
just like an innocuous she she was she
stepped up on a curb and those few
inches is all it took for her to hit the
very top of her head on a tree limb yeah
and there'll be no blood no what it
wasn't just to clarify the joke it
wasn't a gaping wound it's a concussion
he was a concussion no and no no
bleeding on the brain certified by
emergency room but lo and behold over a
year later she has post concussion
syndrome symptoms which is like anyway
she she can't go to the gym that I still
go to because it's too loud she has
sensory issues and she can't move her
head around and throw it around all over
the place so it turns out Pilates you do
jet Jazzercise right and there's a lot
there's a lot of a lot of head bobbing
yeah right it's like not at the Roxbury
another SNL reference
that's what I do every morning I just
start popping it so she goes applauding
so I think my impression of Pilates is
people who have problems and you know he
is for problems yeah and you know in the
eyes for intelligence she has she has
this the the sensory brain and she's you
have the back issues and you're all
there like island of misfit toys on like
some weird Informer what's it called
informer is the guy is the song by snow
but no um it's a reformer and you never
see her there no because I go to the
man's class and she's a woman oh they
don't mix the men in the women's at
Pilates and I used to work out with your
wife they they just don't at this
particular place and then she bailed on
the gym so I'm the only one left of all
three of us who went there look you went
there too yeah we all did let me clarify
because I feel like you're crapping on
Pilates I have an impression that it's
the island of misfit workout and what
say is that you could say the same thing
about any sort of exercise that's
low-impact and can be considered
therapeutic because yoga could be the
same thing people who are people who are
having issues and can't do high stress
exercise Pilates yoga but Pilates is
really really really difficult it's just
basically it's as difficult as you make
it because you're using your body weight
on this reformer not in former rough um
and it's uh I don't know it's great and
if you do it oh no I don't know it's
great if you do it enough and you and
you do it long enough you can't get
ripped doing it but I'm not doing it to
get ripped I'm just doing it because my
I want my back to be functional and I
don't want to be like an 80 year old man
within the four year olds body but you
want your old man in 80 year olds body
but you want cardio so you resolved in
2018 to resolved it's a road work I
don't light resolutions because
resolutions fail what I decided I was
going to do is I said I would like to
get up at the same time every day
because I keep hearing so many people
say that you need to get into a rhythm
you need to get up at the same time you
know every single day and I'm getting up
I'm actually only getting up once a week
for Pilates because of my other class is
an evening class and like what if I got
up at the same time 6:00 a.m. every
single day walk to the couch and went
back to sleep and I was like I can't do
Pilates every single day I don't really
want to go back to the place that you're
at because I hurt my back at the place
that you're at hmm I just want to go to
a place that's got some classes but it's
also got like some machines I can get on
and you know put my headphones on and
listen to other podcasts besides ours
because I don't listen to ours because
I'm listening to it now as it happens it
goes out of your mouth and into your ear
and so yes I did join a gym and I had
have you ever thought were the first
people that listen to our podcast
nevermind go ahead it's just a stupid
self-serving everyone else in the room
right now it's also let me keep going
Jacob we're listening as well yeah why
question that sometimes but I I made it
one solid week getting up at 6:00 a.m.
and getting to the gym I sweated like
I've never sweated before I
what pours you've never done that before
I haven't I haven't sweated out of pours
in a while I've been sweating right on
my mouth no it's not true brother just
my nails in my mouth no I uh and I took
a shower at the gym I was I was in the
show I was like I was one of those dudes
that was showering at the gym and then I
was fixing my hair in the mirror at the
gym I was a gym guy for a week five days
and then I got me I pushed it too hard
man I got sick I got as cold and when
you don't get sick from working out yes
you do read up on the internet link what
do you mean
are you crazy dude yeah yeah yeah we may
week it may be stressing you know yeah
you don't get seasick right you can't
blame it on that yes you can't get sick
from you stress your viruses you stress
your body out and it becomes your your
immune system is busy trying to repair
your muscles and then you get exposed to
a virus and you make yourself weaker I
work myself too hard too fast five days
in a row came since I was sore
I became susceptible to the virus the
virus got me it's the Jemez fault
and so now I'm you know I'm two weeks
into this and I've only got one week of
gym under my belt but I'm gonna have to
just get back up and start again
because getting up at the same time that
one week that I was doing it it was very
helpful and I was using that I know you
started using that Apple bedtime yes app
which tells you when to go to bed you if
you would like to get seven and a half
hours of sleep you need to go to bed now
so in minutes do you go to bed at 10:30
which is like so early for my household
my kids don't go to bed at 10:30 like
I'm the first one going to bed oh wow I
mean my kids do they're supposed to but
like our family McLaughlin's are not
like the Neels yeah yeah yeah it's if we
don't we I'm not gonna ridicule you for
that we're not embarrassed we're not on
a schedule to say that I I now go to I'm
in bed at 9:30 yeah and I I am actually
embarrassed by that you should be
embarrassed there's so much life to be
lived so much TV do you watch so much
food to be eaten late into the night and
I I get up at 8:45 no just kidding I get
up at 5:20 yeah well my goal is to work
my
way to 530 because I would like to
because I'm cutting it close I'm cutting
it close sometimes getting here a little
bit late you know yeah I've noticed that
well that's the other thing kind of kind
of you know there was it was a blow to
to my routine that like okay you're like
we can't you know we got to go to this
gym so we can't carpool anymore I'm a
little concerned about that it's like
well we had carpool three out of five
days probably yeah I can still in week I
can still call you yeah yeah you can
call me on the way in yeah we do that
the person we don't carpool we end up
talking on the phone on the way in
because it's we just can't get enough of
each other
no way well it's you once you once you
get in here and we're like in like
execution mode like and to be clear
we're killing people killing people like
cutting their heads up that's really the
20:18 rhett and Link is just killing
people left and right you just can't
have idle conversation or you can't talk
about things that we need to just you
know the stuff that flutters through the
gaps flutters through the gaps
that's my resolution for 2018 don't let
things flutter don't let anything
flutter through the gaps but so yeah you
got to do it more than a week to make it
a make it a habit yeah but let's get
into the rabbit hole in just a second
but first we want to let you know about
something very exciting that is
amazon.com slash mythical yes
amazon.com slash mythical we've got its
place we've got exclusive merch
dedicated to that location that whatever
size you need these designs in rest
assured you can get it this is a
rhettandlink mixtape which actually
doesn't exist which is cool because you
have to have the shirt to make it exist
on your person because we actually never
made a mixtape that looked like this
this is just a graphic but this is one
of many different weeks we leave the
mini mixed hey yeah but not when is that
written like we didn't write rhett and
Link on it they said things like Minnie
Pearl goes to the race or something like
that right our first our first comedy
recordings in any form were audio
recordings and that's what I maybe we're
coming interview with the bed yeah
interview with the sleeping man I can't
remember we talked about this on
a long time ago but there's other
designs at amazon.com slash mythical so
check those out and we're rotating
different things in and out of there
and as I said on-demand print on demand
your size if you want it come get it
it's there for the taking
yeah and I think a few other products
are also there right I think we yeah
we've got the the grooming products
beard and lady stuff the beard oil the
lip balms and all that's also on Amazon
so thanks for supporting entertainment
and wrapping your peeps which is us wrap
your peeps amazon.com slash mythical
right let's get into this link you want
to do the honors of opening this up okay
where is this gonna take us who knows
got a little number five on the outside
I am nuts uh Corelli commented what
would happen if you took a guy from
middle centuries and just dropped him
somewhere randomly in this century what
would his reaction be I love how this
question is you know like like we know
this and like we can talk about this for
you know like forty minutes of course we
can talk about this we're gonna talk
about whatever this makes us talk about
if you took a guy like if I mean we mean
middle is just from middle cent middle
centuries I mean let's just say you're
going back to Middle Ages the beginning
of time but at the beginning of humanity
you know a hundred a couple hundred
thousand years or whatever and then no
we're not talking about that hundred
gatherer right because the
hunter-gatherer would be paralyzed it
would be essentially the same as
dropping like a chimpanzee into the
middle of New York City well it would be
like putting me put in a virtual reality
headset on me for the first time which
you know when we were at Sundance and
they had this whole Expo where they have
the latest virtual reality technology
and short films that people have made
experimenting pushing the genre and when
when I went we waited in this line
I end up to come back and still wait it
in a line and we put on all of this garb
and it was so it wasn't just a headset
but it was all it was it was gloves and
it was shoes shoes and like shirt by I
put on underwear thigh things I didn't
put it like torso things and I had
underwear on thank god the guy was
dressing me and I felt like a knight
from the Middle Ages so at this point if
if I was from the Middle Ages oh so
you're saying this we are considering
the Middle Ages not not the middle
century we can we can consider whatever
you want
let's our Middle Ages first I'm saying
Middle Ages it was like I was a knight
and my squire was putting all this VR
stuff on me and then you right beside me
and he puts all this stuff on except for
the headset and then he puts and I'd
never done VR before I'd never had an
oculus rift on this if this was a couple
of years ago two three years ago and I
was just I had not been interested in it
I don't want to do that VR stuff until
until this and then he finally puts the
VR headset he's standing right in front
of me on my face like brings it down and
immediately I'm in a world I'm in the
future immediately while you're in VR
and I I was ecstatic and the first thing
I did instinctively was both of my hands
just thrust up in front of me so I could
look at him and the moment I thrust my
hands in front of me I I felt that my
index finger and my middle finger from
my right hand had been forcefully thrust
into the mouths of the guy who had
dressed me yeah in it not only into his
mouth but it went in front of his teeth
and behind his lip like my two fingers
were like jammed up and like in here you
almost did dental damage like I could
it's like I could have I could have
broken through to the sinus camp
yeah right you could have killed him
because if you go up high now if you hit
the brain not Dennis so forcefully and I
was I was and I said whoa and he and I
then I was like I'm sorry and I like I
moved my hand down of course I never saw
the guy he wasn't in the future with
right he didn't have all the gear
and I said well I'm sorry I didn't know
you were there and he said don't worry
it happens all the time
and he was literally it's like it was
like he was in my ear he was that close
well he didn't back well I mean I said I
don't believe horrible I don't believe
that it happens all the time and I mean
that the same thing happened to me and I
didn't I didn't infiltrate anyone's
mouth did you where did your hand go I
knew there was a guy in front of me
putting the the thing on me because I
could tell he was putting it on me
so yeah I was I was maintaining an
awareness in VR and the real world at
the same time that is right not one of
your strong suits no but never done it I
mean how can one maintain a dual reality
we're doing it all the time
but okay but let me let me just say that
this is an interesting question because
you tend to think about things like well
you know any technology that is
introduced too soon there's a famous
quote probably by Isaac Asimov which
essentially says you know any technology
that is not understood is just magic to
people whatever I know that's a horrible
paraphrase he probably didn't even say
it and correct me in the comments Isaac
Hayes maybe but it's essentially is you
immediately just think that something is
coming from the supernatural if you have
no category to put it in and so
especially if you already have a mindset
that is predisposition to believe in the
supernatural which everyone in the
Middle Ages believed that so every
single thing that this dude would be
seeing whether it was the screen of a
phone or a television or a car the
sounds all the technology would be
immediately interpreted as hell magic
and it would either be hell or heaven I
think he would immediately think that he
was in hell or heaven because again that
would be the predominant there's no way
there's that much advertising in heaven
but he wouldn't interpret it as
advertising or even screens
he wouldn't interpreted as a screen just
like I didn't interpret him disk the
screen on my face as a screen I
interpreted it as another world where
there was not well an open-mouth in
front of me it's arthur c clarke any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic Thank You
Jacob I was wrong about the science
fiction Arthur Arthur Arthur C Clark
author but you know what I was saying
anyway but I think the more interesting
thing is not just to think about the
immediate technological things that
would be interpreted as magic because
that's easy you know we know that but
the things that we take for granted the
way that we see ourselves the position
that we see ourselves in the world based
on the things that we know about things
like very simply knowing that we're on a
rock
that's hurtling through space I think we
underestimate just how much that impacts
the way that we think about things
whereas if you go back to the year you
know a thousand everybody just thought
they were the center of the universe and
everybody just thought they were on a
flat you know disk or whatever even
though surprisingly there are still
people who think we're all flat disk now
but I I just like to think just
conceptually the way we think about
things and how different it is
and it was so many of these things we
take for granted we don't keep having
the same sort of conversations about
these things because you just born into
a culture where you take all these
things for granted like the fact that
there's bacteria you know mm-hmm you
wash your hands
is that what you mean he would need to
wash his hands maybe he didn't know that
well it makes me think are we at a point
now when you know with the the the
revolutions that we've gone through the
technological revolution the internet
revolution that are we prepared for
anything so I think the question is if
you took us and plopped us as far into
the future as the Middle Ages would be
till now what I just I feel like we
wouldn't freak out it's so good you're
wrong like I
freak out but no no no but your I
believe you're wrong because of a
principle called the acceleration of
change we talked about this many times
before but and that is the difference
between now and the Year 1000 is much
less compared to the difference between
now and a thousand years from now
because things would change a lot more
but our mindset and ability to be open
to it is different I mean in the
Enlightenment what no what was it I mean
before and after the Enlightenment what
you're assuming by saying that first of
all is pretty presumptuous maybe a
little bit Eric well it's the future we
have to presume a lot because what
you're saying is that we have learned
more than there is to learn
we've learned more in the past 1000
years than there is to learn in the next
1000 no no no no I agree with what
you're saying about the the acceleration
of change but there's a mindset that's
like you know what I'm up for anything
I'm I you know anything is possible
well conjecture about AI and stuff like
that ok ok ok here's where yeah you know
there's people who there's people whose
lives are dedicated 110 percent to
conjecturing about things about the
future in all the different now that
what you're saying is now that we're in
the middle of a quick of a quick
changing landscape yeah like we need
them what surprised me so in other words
if you go back to the middle middle age
night there were no he had no
contemporaries that are like writing
science fiction at the time predicting
what was gonna be next sure there might
be like a Leonardo da Vinci down the
street who was like jumping off of a
building and trying to fly but to think
that oh one day there's gonna be this
thing that flies around that has this
thing called a camera which is like an
eye and it's gonna be able to send the
thing that it's seeing back to a little
device that a man has and he can look
and see talking about a drone and you
tell him out of draw hey let me get it
straight you talk about drone and we all
so are constantly being bombarded with
things that are impossibility is because
of CGI so we can watch movies not only
can we read books and and imagine things
that are impossible we can actually see
those things come into physical reality
VR as an example or movies as an example
not physical reality but you know visual
reality yeah and so we can see things
that aren't real so we're actually we're
used to seeing things that are clearly
not real and not thinking they're magic
because we know that technology can
produce those things it has a pretty
good point but I still think that you're
under estimating like think about how
crazy of a of a technological movement
the the internet was I there's there you
you realize there's there's something
there's something that's not in the the
predictive capabilities of people that's
gonna happen just chance that that's not
gonna happen
I think about this like if you if you
plucked me from now and then plopped me
in the future and on a on the precipice
of a Kasim Kasim and then beside me is
did you see that movie no is that a
movie Kasim tell me you talking about
well then no I haven't seen it
and then beside me on the precipice is
Indiana Jones Harrison Ford her Indiana
Jones Indiana Jones the character yeah
and he says walk out there just like you
saw in the movie that I was in by the
way I'm not the guy from the movie I'm
the real guy in the future I'm I exist
now if I believed I'd been plopped into
the future I would I could believe the
Indiana Jones part okay somehow in the
future I bet you're a bit you're AI a
bit you're you could be a hologram you
could you could be real you could be
flesh bone to the core and you could be
if you told me if I asked you in Indy
you told me how you were produced I
could buy all of it and I would just be
like okay I'm not good I'm not freaking
out
I'm like wow somebody was right somebody
who predicted this was right I didn't
read the book but they were right but
then I don't know if I would walk out
like he did in the movie and without
throwing the dust out and even I threw
the dust out and I saw that there was
some sort of a invisible path across a
chasm but if you dropped me if you
plucked me from here and then popped me
out on that path I would have a I would
have a visceral emotional response I
would freak out I would go into shock
because I would think I should be
falling through and I wasn't so I'm not
saying that you couldn't freak me out
but I'm saying if you've set me in an
office chair and you like informed me
and educated me of these things I just
think office chair there's no such thing
as an office chair I was in years from
now I just think we're that well are our
minds are that is this another way of
saying what you're saying is that we
have crossed some sort of threshold of
possibilities openness to possibilities
that didn't exist before and you don't
think that there's another threshold
that we can't even foresee that then
would just be so mind-blowing that then
you would conclude things you would be
trying again in the same way that the
Middle Ages man takes what he's seeing
and he categorizes it right you only can
categorize things according to
categories that exist in your own mind
so if you're from the Year 1000 and you
see the modern day you're like I'm in
heaven or hell I why there's no other
possibility I'm obviously not in earth
I'm not on earth but you think that
you've got enough categories now you
think that you've got categories of like
it might be parallel universes it might
be some sort of simulation it might be
some something where my brain is being
manipulated in a way this may be a
hallucination induced by a drug what
there's so many different possibilities
that you as a modern man can appreciate
the level yeah the the level of trauma
because I think that's the answer to the
question what would you
reaction be if he was plopped here it
would be utter trauma it would be
permanent damage and you don't think
that you would the brain traumatized so
what you're saying is and you may be
right there's not another category
loading over over a chasm so you don't
think that there's not another walking
game changing the technological
threshold that will happen
well that will I know it wouldn't
mentally change you make a good point in
it because this is a trap right if I say
if I say no there's no new category that
there's no box there's no new box that I
don't have that I could throw whatever I
would experience when plopped into the
future into well that's that's exactly
what I'm saying well let's use music as
an example right because if you go back
to go back to the 40's right and then
play post Malone post Malone okay since
we just hanging around with us you play
piece of the brain you play post Malone
for somebody in the 40s and what is
there okay so we know the kind of
reaction they would have that we can
anticipate it would be like I don't
understand what's happening I can
vaguely recognize that there's a couple
of words beeped but I don't understand
why I don't necessarily wouldn't
categorize it as music right right right
it would be an alien language but do you
think that there is a music genre that
will be created that would be surprising
to us in the same way that post Malone
would be to somebody from the 1940s or
do you think it's like no I mean at this
point any combination of noises could be
music because like you know yeah I think
at this point any combination of noises
would not surprise me if you told me it
was music because if you think about EDM
I wouldn't be surprised this is good
this would be surprised by the sounds
and that it that it was enjoy
by people and I have an opinion about it
but I wouldn't be surprised that it was
music right because if you think about
EDM EDM one way to see EDM is and I'm
not gonna say EDM music cuz that's like
saying ATM machine okay so I'm just
gonna say EDM it's good if and why can't
we just call it
eeehm because why do you have to dance
to it you know what I'm saying do you
have to dance to it why can't it just be
a.m. I'm sure I'm sure there are you
think I've never heard a.m. everybody
says EDM we're not cool enough to have
heard about it is there just a.m. that
you don't dance to I hope I've never
danced to EDM we'd probably like it but
I would say without a doubt that they're
probably albums out and there's probably
a song out right now and probably this
was what the composer was thinking when
he or she put the song together I'm
going to create a song that has every
single frequency that can be understood
and perceived by a human ear to be in
this song that's an easy thing right if
in if any of you idiom producers haven't
done that yet get on it right catch up
with the e/m producers so basically
every single sound for lack of a better
way to put this encapsulate it in one
song at least every frequency and
there's only so many frequencies that we
can hear and with the technology that we
have right now you think it because we
can't we can generate every single
frequency in any given song well and
I'll go one further and and then scrunch
it all down into a millisecond but then
wool now you're in the mathematical
mathematical territory because what is
the minimum amount of time required for
the human brain to perceive every single
frequency and can you just do it all at
once in one split second and there's
something about our brains in our ears
in the future are we in the future
present by the way well you may I don't
want to throw off your your your thought
experiment so finish your thought I'm
using music as an analogy
to try to try to try to ask whether or
not your perspective is correct about
theirs you're basically saying that you
cannot be surprised you could be
surprised but you would not be
traumatized by the future because you're
open to all possibilities because you're
a modern man that is on this side of the
technological revolution yeah and more
specifically the internet revolution
yeah
and so I'm saying that music okay and I
would say on the precipice of the
artificial intelligence revolution like
I talked I talked to things that aren't
listening now because I talked to the
freaking Google home and the Alexa like
I've they are listening they are
listening but now I've you know I found
myself wanting to talk to my sink
we got a fact here a team of neuro
scientists from MIT has found that the
human brain can process entire images
that the eye sees for as little as 13
milliseconds yeah so then you start
writing a song and then you scrunch it
into 13 milliseconds and in the future
somehow our brains have been tweaked or
tweaked or they've been added on to with
technology so that you can experience
like a world of song in 13 milliseconds
I mean that would it wouldn't it
wouldn't traumatize me I wouldn't be
like oh my gosh
I'm I must be burning in hell right now
you know it's like I took it what I was
saying was I talked to I talked to my
refrigerator by accident now I'm like
okay refrigerator make me a smoothie you
know it's like I I haven't actually said
that but I in the same way that like but
you should but my my yeah I mean we
really need that my kitchen sink I
touched the faucet it turns on I don't
have to turn the you know I'm now I'm
constantly touching faucets other
people's because you got that faucet
because I had that faucet yeah that's
right and so touched your faucet and
water came out and now we have that I
gotta have my own faucet to touch and
now we've got that faucet
at the office but you have to touch the
base of this faucet where you can just
touch the in tiny metal part of our
process I touch I touch
everybody's faucet now and I'm
disappointed when it doesn't produce
water it's like what thing won't cut on
I talked I talked to my children and I
asked him to do things
okay Lincoln take out the trash and he
and I'm disappointed because he's not
like Google and Alexa but he is in the
Serie isn't a certain way because often
he does something that you did not ask
him to do I mean that's what Alexa does
yeah for me quite often and we can see
the future
that you know and we know that they're
listening you know we're being served
ads when we based on conversations that
we're having with other people so freaks
me out
you okay you're saying there's
absolutely no future that would
ultimately traumatize you surprise you
you know because you may also when we
would have to somehow you were to learn
that well if our world was just a
figment of your imagination as long as
mine what if your are the people you
should look this up because some people
is a pretty good theory that the entire
world is just Ed Sheeran's dream okay
this is a really interesting theory and
just go with me here and I'm sorry if
you're an edge here and fan you're gonna
be you're gonna be insulted here in a
second now I'm not saying that I'm I'm
not I don't consider myself an edge here
and fan I think he's a talented guy I
think that he's got very catchy music I
think that he seems like a good guy he's
got a few too many Shrek tattoos but
whatever you know a lot of people make
mistakes but if you were to go into a
coffee shop and you were to see you got
something to him now just to clarify
Jacob don't get it in the shot Jacob
because I'm about to say that
Jacob is just he's our AI it's just a
box over there okay Jacob
hand me your computer with an edge
Sheeran article entitled scientist
confirm we are all living in Ed
Sheeran's dream yeah so this is from the
daily mash which it was John yeah it's a
joke article but the point of this is is
this and I haven't read that article
I've just had a conversation with a
friend who had seen that and he thought
this was a really interesting theory put
yourself in a situation where you go
into a coffee shop ten years ago and you
go in there and there's this there's ed
Sheeran and he's edge hearing before
he's ed Sheeran right it's just a dude
and he's playing like a famous he's
playing an Ed Sheeran song on the
acoustic guitar and he's doing some like
singing and some interesting rapping
sort of white dude rapping rapping kind
of thing and you're like this guy's this
guy's pretty good hey honey you should
we should give him a tip you know I'm
saying like that's how you would respond
to seeing ed Sheeran ten years ago in a
cafe right yeah I know I'm tempted to
buy a CD but I know if I do I'll listen
to it and then I won't be as good as it
was live whatever this internal dialogue
is gonna in with me not buying a CD
right now going to the same coffee shop
Beyonce is in there you'd be like what
who is this woman why is she at this
coffee shop this is she's got so much
talent and her little finger she
shouldn't be in a coffee shop she should
be on stage in front of millions of
people she's amazing
this is crazy this is a once in a
lifetime Talent that's how you would
respond to seeing Beyonce in a coffee
shop yeah but the fact is is that Edie
Sheeran not Beyonce was the number one
most downloaded artist on Spotify last
year
isn't that right look that up I think
I'm right about that he sells out arenas
just like Beyonce does so many people
are led to believe that a normal dude
with a normal level of music okay he's
an exceptionally talented person well
you know what Frodo destroyed the one
ring yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you bet
Sam movie exactly exactly that didn't
happen in real life that's a frickin
story out of tokens
mine's really Sam you know what I'm
saying and worse yeah so you're playing
right into this because the story that
we all want to tell is that the underdog
wins right and the underdog but that's
what we see in movies I always see in
real life but Ed Sheeran is the classic
example of just a normal dude dominating
and so it could be true that this is
just me and you and this whole
conversation are just a figment of Ed
Sheeran's imagination in the world where
he decided that he was gonna be the man
most streamed artist on Spotify
ed Sheeran confirmed fact you tell me
how we don't know that we're not a
figment of Ed Sheeran's well the most I
mean the most viewed channel on YouTube
is a kid talking about toys you know I
feel like I can explain that though
because a lot of children no I think are
left just in front of a computer screen
and they love to watch unboxing videos
of their peers talking about toys and
their kid in parents just leave that you
leave YouTube on for them just endlessly
that's why so much of the YouTube
algorithm or not algorithm but just
what's popular on YouTube is so driven
by kids tastes I can understand that I
can I can explain that but the only
imagination is that he's this is his
this is his world I'm just saying that
it's plausible you cannot tell me that
it's impossible that we are not just a
figment of Ed Sheeran's imagination no
way to prove it and it makes sense that
he would have just like ed Sheeran ed
Sheeran if this were just all his
imagination within that imagination he
would have two dudes on the internet
right now talking about how this was all
his imagination because that's the
perfect layering the perfect play it's
the perfect way to throw you off of his
trail
ed she we are being pond we are ponds we
are ed Sheeran spawns right now having
this conversation perpetuating this idea
that this is a thing we're a figment of
his imagination because we are a figment
of his imagination
true we should keep talking about ed
Sheeran and how this is not his world so
that he will continue to to make us more
popular well this makes me think about
the thing that we were talking about the
other day which is you know we talk
often about whether or not we're in a
simulation and now there's really no way
to prove it and you know recently some
scientists said that they prove that we
are not in a simulation and I and I read
the science in just one article and I
was not convinced I was not convinced
but this you know the theory goes that
at some point in a civilizations
timeline they will have the ability to
generate a reality a virtual reality
that is indistinguishable from reality
and if that's going to happen it's going
to happen millions of times and and any
given any given civilization will be
able to do it millions of times just the
only limitation is their computing power
and Andy Serkis will be really busy
right and that means that just
statistically speaking that we're
probably in one of those simulations
because there's going to be that many
more simulations than there are
realities right and so I've been
thinking about that and then I was like
well what if we are in a simulation
right now but we're essentially avatars
and we are playing a game we talked
about this the other day and we are
there's there's a real being that's
controlling me this avatar yeah you that
avatar matrix situation and the in life
is essentially a computer game that
we're all playing and somebody's keeping
score you know the game the game master
God whoever you want to call that and
there's a way to beat the game and I was
sitting in my hot tub a couple weeks ago
and I was like what if the way that you
break out of the simulate simulation is
just saying that you know it's a
simulation and saying that you want to
get out of it if there was some sort of
way that you could be like okay guys I
know it's a simulation I'm ready to get
out
and I was in my hot tub can i right now
come
can I please ask you not to continue
this story I don't want you to tell them
what you told me I don't want them to
know what you did next do you remember
what I did next I remember what you did
next I was just about to say what I did
next I know and I'm just I don't know
okay fine tell them I was basically
saying it I just said out loud I know
this is a simulation and I'm ready to
get out he said it out loud and I'm
still here
so you actually tried it I did
so either you didn't have to tell
anybody you did that no I did I did not
tell me what that's what the ear
biscuits
that's what ear biscuits are about
manners secret was safe with me dude I
was never going to tell anybody that's
what your biscuits are about okay but
let me tell you what I learned by saying
that you could probably cover it up
right now you could back up you could
say you know what back up you know what
I did I thought it'd be funny to say it
out loud do I learn for everybody that
eh that is not the way out of the
simulation okay
I've confirmed how you get out so don't
try it you don't have to try it
it is the blow lobe moment or B we're
not in a simulation I mean those are the
two options but I need a baby we're in
one and I'm still I just don't know the
way out maybe you gotta learn a
different language maybe you have to
talk to someone else into doing it and
then you blow hold hands yeah come on
let's do it man okay whatever listen I
wouldn't it be so awesome if we were
recording a podcast in this simulation
right now we're the one then we all of a
sudden the headphones just fall to the
ground because we leave and then that is
broadcast back to the people in the
Select obi-wan yes hold my hand yeah
just hold and do it hold my hand now we
need to say our names and we need to be
an agreement and we need to have faith
okay this is like faith has it shouldn't
have anything to do with it no this is
like Indiana Jones man this is like
throwing the sand out you got to take
the step
well if it is a freaking hand it is
about faith you shouldn't throw the sand
out because that always wanted wow that
always bumped me it's like why did he
throw the sand out that's not faith well
if it's got to be based on something you
know I can't he's be blind you got to
throw some sand out here's the sand it's
my hand hold it man
well that's the part that doesn't make
sense let's say okay we're let's say we
are retinol e for the for the for the
fresh listeners I'm currently holding
his hand and we're gonna say we are
rhettandlink and we know we're in a
simulation and we want out now do we
know if we want a hug there's just think
about how cool it will be if we figure
out that we're in one and we get out
come on man there we go you got what do
you want me to repeat what we're gonna
say or you got it I got it
where y'all can read now come on and you
got you don't you're not be first for
this you think that'll screw it up
that's fine you can we can be linking
red for this that's fine as long as we
get out they're gonna think it's at
first and let's say we are yeah we are
we two guys are lenient and red and just
say the and really clearly so does it
sound like Lincoln writ like a guy named
Lincoln right you go we two guys are
link and Rhett and we oh we know we are
in a sensation and we want out now okay
let's start okay we two guys are rent
and stuff I suffice it's a habit man
it's a habit it's years of saying it the
right way
oh here we go we two guys are linked and
read and we know we are in a simulation
and we want out now
maybe it takes a second you didn't have
enough faith man or now you didn't take
it seriously feel it in your hand what
if the sweat is from your hand maybe
next year wow you disappointed actually
hold on this is the moment we celebrate
that this is reality
yeah it's just like again what you had
said a second ago was it still sorry
about it I figured it out
this is not a simulation it's too simple
and now we no way that's the way out
there's no way that's the way it's got
to be a little door somewhere and like
an old Shack why doesn't look like
there's any power or anything going to
the shack but then you open it up and
there's wires and stuff yeah follow the
wires well I tried I really I I
definitely tried my middle ages college
professor wasn't dr. riddle yeah and
why'd you take that class by the way uh
I was taking summer classes this is when
Christy went to the west coast you went
to Slovakia mm-hmm me Matt Newkirk went
to the gym and I took some summer
classes have bumped up and talked like
trash and he was very boring but
occasionally he would tell a story about
the Middle Ages and he told a story he
he was that old he was he was he was
very old he was a thousand years old he
was from the Middle Ages he told a story
about him
I guess it was a legend about a guy who
I don't know if he was a if he was a
thinker philosopher what he was priest
monk I wish I could remember
I don't retain much information but I do
remember that the story goes that he
decided to go to the go to a point in
town and never move and he would he
would crap
there when you don't leave you got a you
got to use the bathroom there and over
many years and many deposits he created
a tower of his own poop that he set up
that he sat upon it sounds like a it
sounds like a fable I believe that it's
true Grimm fairy tales but do you
believe it's true Yuba was yeah so it
was like a guy in the Middle Ages who
supposedly did this he was like David
Blaine yeah but it wasn't like a weekend
in New York City it was like his whole
life his whole life and this story had
no point that I recall well I think we
can well the point is the big pile of
poop that he was but I was riveted by it
so I asked doctor riddle if I could meet
him at his office and interview him yeah
that was the summer that you had the
handheld recorder and you recorded a lot
of things and I I started I got him to
retell that story and many other stories
many other Middle Ages anecdotes that
I've never gone back to III reliving the
tape you know when we were writing the
book I was looking through a lot of
archival stuff that I've kept and I felt
sure that I would have kept the tape but
I never kept it I never found it so I
guess I must have lost it along the way
I wish I had that tape that's it that's
it well I don't I don't know why well I
think we can draw up many conclusions
from this I bet there's something we
learn from that because it's sprung up
in my mind and I just thought it was
important to tell the story one
conclusion with no point in mind you got
to keep moving or else unless you want
to sit on your own poop and gotta keep
moving you can't stay in the same place
for too long get a bed sore or you just
you sit on your own poop why I think I
think analogously
that is a word you know maybe it relates
to the to the whole question go back to
the question you know you NASA you can't
you can't stay where you are
because you'll just be sitting in a pile
of your own crap you
you won't it will not end well for you
you'll be high atop your own crap you
got to be you got to be as open as you
can so you can decrease your chances of
being plopped into a place in the future
where you're gonna freak out and and
become shell shocked a shell of a person
is there something we can do to not be
this Middle Ages guy and is that in is
that a-- is that a virtue well I think
what you're saying is that if you want
to boil this down to a life lesson so
what you're trying to do try I'm trying
to I'm trying to bring it full circle
answer Newton so Corelli's quest to make
it practical well we've already answered
we've already answered the question but
to make it practical if you can get to a
certain threshold in your own mind where
you are willing to be open to the
possibilities of all your disparate
futures so that nothing that happens to
you no matter how good no matter how bad
will be traumatizing traumatizing in
quotes because sometimes it's just gonna
be traumatizing literally physically you
get a horrible disease or you're in an
accident things that we can't avoid but
can you get your mind to a place where
regardless of what the future holds you
can take it in stride that is the lesson
of the question of nuts occur Ellie are
we saying that right or is it nuts ax
that's a I like to say nutzy I don't
know this print out does not have a
pronunciation guide don't be a
closed-minded Middle Ages man who would
be traumatized by a step one thousand
years into the future how do we do that
we realize that we're all in the
simulation most likely the figment of Ed
Sheeran's imagination and therefore if
ed sheeran can think it it could happen
to you
and Ed Sheeran can think of a lot of
things because he makes his rap with
Foulke I just you know I never I did
that there was I just there was not a
ounce of my there was not just an
inkling of myself that thought that
maybe we'd pop out of a simulation I
mean I thought it was fun that we did it
but maybe that's what kept us from it
exactly I had I had a seed I had a seed
of faith well I will say if you had a
point one percent if you're sitting
there all alone and you audibly said
that that I keep going back to that like
it's hilarious to me that like I what
what if I would have like decided to
stop by and like you didn't know I was
coming over or not I've had to sneak up
on me not cuz I didn't know who's at
pool and I came back there and I just
happened to be walking through or I'm
eyes open if jesse was walking through I
mean behind you she wouldn't be as
surprised she deserves you out of the
blue just audibly say what what how did
you put it and I know I'm Lincoln Rhett
I didn't I just said I know I'm in a
simulation and I want out now see for me
it's if I got to the point where I knew
I was in a simulation what I would say
was I know I'm in a simulation and I'm
good with it well then they mean it's
not worth saying at all that's right you
can't if you can't transition out of it
then it's not even worth acknowledging
well I think no I think that isn't
couldn't that be a way forward like
we're talking about well what you're
really talking about is the Morpheus
scene in in in the matrix where he's in
the he's in the white world where he's
given up she take the red pill the blue
pill and you can either take the red
pill and get out of the matrix you can
take the blue pill and go back in and
you're saying that simply asking the
question must have been a good movie if
we're still talking about it it was well
in at the time
and here's a funny thing at the time it
seems so revolutionary I was like how
could this even like I didn't eat well
Matrix Revolutions seemed so rebel I
didn't even I didn't get it I didn't
even get it the first time I saw it and
I didn't even understand fully what was
happening it wasn't until the second
time that I really began to realize that
the real world like implications that
the story had but the thing is is that
people people people people like arthur
c clarke or isaac asimov have been you
know they've been thinking about this
kind of stuff for a long time and then
they died yep and they didn't figure it
out they got closer i wonder if they
were pretty frustrated people i wonder
oh i don't think so i don't know i don't
know i didn't know him personally
sad sad simulation I'm pretty happy
eight I want to meet you I want to be
clear just in closing I want to be clear
that what I said I want out now I wasn't
saying that I don't like this simulation
oh I love the simulation you know you
want to shake the hand of the man who's
making this simulation I am a woman I'm
having a great time I'm having a great
time in the simulation and but just the
thought that there is a more grounded
reality you know I'm a sucker for truth
right and so even if the truth is
unpleasant even if the truth makes me
feel uncomfortable I tend to try to move
towards it and so I I think that if
there's if there's a more grounding
reality underneath this this reality
even if because I mean I mean think
about it that could help you I had that
can help you appreciate like if there
was a positive motive for the simulation
to have been created well let me think
oh now I see why there's the simulation
because this truth is horrible
I don't want me I don't want to keep
going back to the matrix but that's the
whole point of the movie yeah it is
you've got the guy who turns on them and
starts killing them because he wants he
likes it he likes the steak that he's
eating it's good it's real to him yeah
but then you know Morpheus this whole
idea is that no this this the reality
the truth will set you free the truth is
more important than just giving yourself
over to the simulation because
ultimately if you follow the truth
wherever the truth leads you and mankind
will ultimately be better off I have to
believe that I have to believe that
right no you do not I don't have to
believe it but I choose to believe it
and you can also be wrong yeah but you
know so you're saying that I might be in
a weird gelatinous pod right now and
waking up in that and choking on my
amniotic fluid is not a reality that I
really want to experience yeah we could
simulate that within the simulation and
see how you feel
let's do that let's let's inception the
matrix now you're talking yeah now
you're talking when you get a sleeping
bag and some slime and while we're at it
let's add in a few transformers no no no
no nobody needs that well I think we've
solved something today hopefully we
answered your question nutzy and if you
didn't like this one there'll be another
one next week coming right at you and
it'll be different I don't know how we
won't talk about the same stuff yeah but
let us know what you think let's
continue this conversation with you
mythical beast
hashtag ear biscuits yes let us know
your perspective on the stuff that we
talked about maybe we'll engage on
Twitter I'm not gonna make specific
promises but I'm saying there's a
distinct possibility that I are linked
or both of us will engage on Twitter you
want to engage on Twitter yeah let's do
it
hashtag your biscuits
[Music]